نحييكم في هذه الايام المباركه من جارد
الحجه وندى الله ان يعود وطننا الغالي
اكثر امنا واستقرارا بعد دوال هذه التهمه
الفاسده ونعلم من جانبنا الهدنه من جانب
واحد ليوم والوقوف بعرفه وهو الايام اذا
الاضحى المبارك فيما عدا حالات الدفاع عن
النفس ونتمنى ان تكون هذه الايام فرصه
للتسامح والمصالحه بين جميع مكونات جعلنا
الكريم نشعر بمعاناه شعبنا بسبب هذه الحرب
وظروف الانسانيه الصعبه الذي خلفتها في
جميع مناح الحياه وامننا ان نخرج من اكثر
قوه واحده نتابع باهتمام كل الانتهاكات
التي تمارس ضد المدنيين الابرياء من كل
الاطراف وخاصه من قبل قواتنا والاتهامات
بالسرقات وغيرها من التقارير والادعاءات
هذه الانتهاكات تخالف قانون الدعم السريع
وتوجيهاته العليا وتتنصد لها بحزم وجديه
نؤكد بشكل واضح ان موقف
اننا نرفض وندين اي انتهاكات ترتكب ضد
المواطنين بما فيها ما يثبت حدوثه بواسطه
اي منسوي قوات الدعم السريع عليه فقد غمنا
بتشكيل لجنه خاصه بقياده اللواء اسامه
الدين رئيس محكمه الميدان هذه اللجنه
تمتلك كل الصلاحيات بدات عملها في ام
درمان يغادر محاكمات ميدانيه لعدد من
الافراد الذين ارتكبوا انتهاكات ضد
المواطنين وبالمقابل ان لا يتم استخدام
هذه الانتهاكات للمذاهره علينا لتجهيز
الشعب خصوصا انه قد ثبت لدينا ان يجدد
كبير من هذه الجرائم قد تم التخطيط لها
والتنفيذ بواطئ من الانجلابين ومنشيادهم
والاستخبارات العسكريه وجهاد الامن
المخابرات الوطني ترتدي ذي الدعم السريع
والذي تتم صناعته بواسطه مصانع تتبع
للقوات المسلحه نوجه جميع الارتكازات في
ممارسه سيطره قواتنا للتعامل بحسب مظاهر
التفلل والانتهاكات والجرائم التي تمارس
ضد المواطنين
ومحاكمه اي متخلف من الدعم السريع او من
الجامعات الاخرى التي استغلت هذه الازمه
للتعدي على المدنيين وامتلاكاتهم واعراضهم
لثالتنا لجميع المواطنين
وجميع انحاء السودان ان يتعاونوا مع
الغبار بالتبليق والتنسيق للمساعده في حفظ
الامن وتوفير الخدمات الضروريه ولقد بدانا
التعاون مع مواطني عدد من المناطق التي
نسيطر عليها واثبتت هذه التجارب نجاحا
سنعمل على تعميمه وتطويره في بقيه المناطق
ونجدد ايضا دعوتنا للعاملين في القطاعات
الحيويه مثل الكهرباء والمياه والاتصالات
لاستئناف عملهم لضمان استقرار هذه الخدمات
مع استعدادنا التام لترتيب مهمتهم وتوفير
الحمايه والمساعده اللازمه لرفع المعاناه
عن شعبنا الكريم رسالتنا لاهلنا السودان
وخاصه في دارفور يجب عليكم ان تنتبهوا
للمخطرات التي تحاول اشعال الحرب الاهليه
وتكرار المعتل الانسانيه التي وقعت خلال
السنوات الماضيه ونؤكد تواصلنا المستمر مع
حركات الكفاح المسلح ولذلك الاهليه
والمجتمع المدني بالاقليم من اجل ضمان
استقرار الامن وتجنب الانزلاق الاوضاع
للحرب الاهليه الشامله التي تخطط لها
وتعمل عليها اجهزه الفلول فداء الفول لقد
تابعنا ايضا دعوات الفنون للتظاهر في
مناطق العمليات الحربيه انا نحترم حق
التظاهر والتعبير السلمي ولكن هذه الدعوات
هي مؤامره خبيثه لجرى المدنيين اداره
الحرب هذا المخطط يريد تغطيه فشل قوات
الخلود في حربها ضد قواتنا الباسله
باستخدام المدنيين العزل كوقود لهذه الحرب
انها ندعو لعدم الاستجابه لهذه من الدعوات
وتجنب التظاهر في المناطق التي تجري فيها
العمليات العسكريه حاليا على سلامه
المواطنين الابرياء ان محاوله الفنون
لاستنجاد المدنيين مثير للسخريه فمن يعرض
المدنيين ودورهم لا يغسلهم بالطيران
المدفعيه كما يحدث الان وحدث من قبل في
مناطق عديده من البلاد ان الغديه الوطنيه
الذي نواجهها في هذا الظرف الدقيق نتطلب
الوحده وتكاثف من الجميع للقضاء على هؤلاء
الفاسدين الذين دمروا السودان وما زالوا
يدعون لاستعاده حكمهم ليمارس مزيدا من
الاذلال لشعبنا التحيه والتقدير لاشابه
الدعوه السريع الذين سطروا ملاحم بطوليه
التاريخ
درسا قاسيا في الشجاعه والاقدام نحييكم
ونشد من اجركم وندعوكم الى معسله النضال
بذات الثبات والعزيمه التي نعرفها عنكم
هذه الحرب فرضت علينا وهي ليست ضد القوات
المسلحه بل ضد الذين اختطفوا قرارها من
اراد داخل المؤسسه العسكريه